a microbiologist has 1
microbes growing in culture when he
checks again after 15 minutes there are
283 microbes in the same culture so they
they're growing pretty fast estimate the
difference between the number of
microbes at each check by rounding each
number to the nearest ten so what they
want us to do they want us to round each
number to the nearest ten and then with
the rounded numbers find the difference
between the two checks so let's round
each of these numbers so we started with
microbes so 1250
microbes so how do we round this to the
nearest ten that's what they want us to
do so you look at the tens place the
tenths place is that five right there so
if we round it up it would go to a six
if we round it down it would stay at a
5. if we round it up this would be 60 if
we round it down this will be 50. and
the rule for rounding is you look at the
place one below that you go to the ones
place in this case and you see if that
is five or more then or five or greater
and it is it's six which is definitely
five or greater so we want to round up
so we want to
round
round up and we're rounding up to the
nearest 10. so this will go from 56 to
60. so it'll be
we've rounded up now when we wait 15
minutes we check and we see that there
are
2283 microbes
2283 microbes once again let's look at
the tens place
that's the 8 right there let me do that
in a different color that is the 8 right
there and you look at the place 1 below
that if that's 5 or greater you round up
otherwise you round down this right here
3 is less than 5 so you want to round
down
round
we want to round down so we're going to
be left with 2
200 instead of 83 we're just going to
have 80 2
280.
now they want us to estimate the
difference between the number of
microbes at each check by rounding each
number to the nearest 10 so we've we've
done that part we've rounded each number
to the nearest 10 now we have to find
the difference so let's subtract the
first check from the second check that's
we get a positive number so let's do
that so if we subtract this this 1260
let me just copy and paste it
so we want to subtract this
copy it and paste it we want to subtract
that from the
2280 to figure out the difference
so we're gonna subtract here let me put
the subtraction sign and let's do some
subtraction so you go first to the ones
place
zero minus zero well that's just going
to be 0
8 minus 6 in the tens place it's really
80 minus 60 that's going to be 2 but
since in the 10 place it's 20 or you can
just do 80 minus 60 is 20. so everything
makes sense so far 2 minus 2 is 0 and
then 2 minus 1 is 1. so when we rounded
each number to the nearest 10 and then
took the difference our estimated
difference is 1020.